michigan's governor is under fire
again for violating her own covet
guidelines
again after getting caught unmasked
dining out with a bunch of friends about
a dozen the governor responding in part
quote
i went with friends to a local
restaurant as more people arrived the
tables were pushed together
because we were all vaccinated we didn't
stop to think about it
in retrospect i should have thought
about it i am
human i made a mistake i apologize
fox news contributor ben dominic is here
with reaction good morning to you ben
good morning to you peter i too am human
hold it
of course humans can make mistakes right
and you just did but
you just you're thinking of the tall guy
at the white house
oh i'm so sorry
[Laughter]
you're as bad as she is i just think i
just think that one of the things
that is going on here is that you have a
governor who has been
so vociferous in chiding her people
in undercutting them in bringing them
down in
you know going after them in so many
different respects uh and and yet when
you
look at this uh you know situation you
have someone who has uh
repeatedly violated her own orders or
stretched them in different ways
you saw the whole experience with her
husband going wanting to go out on a
boat
and citing you know do you know who i am
earlier and that's what we've seen from
all of these politicians through this
whole process
where they're unwilling to grant grace
or forgiveness or
understand humans who are going to make
mistakes or violate rules in different
respects
instead they go after them hamer and
tongs and yet they want a different
standard for themselves
sure and this latest instance where she
broke her own rules
there are about a dozen people the rules
are six
people or fewer at tables they actually
put three or four tables together
distances of six feet feet between
tables indoor
capacity at 50 or 100 people on and on
and you look at it and you know what uh
you mentioned her husband
then of course in june of 2020 she
joined the
george floyd protest violated her own
social distancing rule
republicans called for investigations
into her handling of nursing homes
top aide traveled to florida for spring
break after being told don't do that
uh she went on a private plane to visit
her father
and then the latest thing is she
violated it at the land shark bar
but ben she's a politician does anybody
really
expect her to follow her own rules come
on
well of course i mean you know obviously
politicians are better than the rest of
us that's the thing that we all have to
understand
you know they are our ruling class our
elite and so the rules shouldn't apply
to them they should be able to get
away with all manner of things you know
that's what we learned during the entire
hunter biden experience that you don't
even actually have to be a politician
you can just be related to one
and then the rules just don't apply to
you in this case though
i think seriously looking back at the
way that this pandemic was treated these
lockdowns were treated
not just by whitmer but by gavin newsom
by so many different
officials across the country we've seen
these repeated violations
of the rules that they've set up for us
and my response to that is
we shouldn't have the ability of these
politicians
uh to set up these rules in the first
place right their emergency powers turn
out to be a lot more powerful
than i think all of us really expected
them to be and their ability to crack
down on american citizens
and take away their freedoms quickly
turned out to be a lot more significant
than we thought in the first place
that's something that we needed to go
back and revisit and one thing in
particular
i think that this is a situation where
we ought to have
more of an ability to recall governors
across the country
just as they do in california whether it
results in them not being elected or not
it will at least have that threat put in
place that makes them think twice about
violating their rules in these ways you
know ben i've got friends down in
florida who
spend the summer in michigan they're not
going back
because of the restrictions that were
put in place at the beginning of the
pandemic when we didn't know a lot
fast forward we know so much more and
now people are going wait
what exactly did we give away which was
your point the kind of point that you
make on the ben dominic podcast it's
available at foxnewspodcast.com
all right benjamin thank you very much
so much you bet